okay so the book of boba fett has had
three great episodes so far if you ask
me yeah you might not like them though
but i like them just let me like what i
like please i like the little speeder
bike scene at the moment though we're
still pretty early on and the season is
in full setup mode which allows us to
speculate every single week and make
videos on what could be happening to
blue milk this entire thing dry there's
the potential of a big villain some
major cameos being reported on and all
in all there's a lot to look forward to
now after watching episode 3 for the
second time i actually think there's a
pretty big thing that no one has talked
about yet during the flashback section
of the entry we see boba travel into mos
eisley the fabled town of scum and
villainy that looks like my youtube
comments when i say i like the little
bike thing on the way he passed a set of
stormtrooper helmets being put onto
spikes and also pelimoto who you will
probably know from the mandalorian now
right after this baba returned home to
find that the tuscans had been wiped out
by the nictos raiders that's where we
last saw him and i think it might
actually hint towards what's gonna
happen in either the next episode or the
one after it because of the stormtrooper
helmets being put under spikes and
barber passing pali motto i actually
think that this will be happening right
before episode 5 of the mandalorian in
that we saw mando arrive on tatooine and
in a hangar he came face to face with
pelly after meeting with her he passed
the same stormtrooper helmets on spikes
and then met a young gunslinger in the
military cantina the pair decided to
team up to take down fenix shand and the
entry ended with boba walking towards
her body now i actually think that the
flashback of episode 4 will tie in with
this moment and that we'll actually see
barbara's actions whilst all this is
going on when he found fennick it seemed
like he was completely alone and i can
imagine that after finding the camp
destroyed that he started to wander the
desert i believe that because of the
flashback moments in episode 3 that we
will get a part in episode 4 where he
comes across her body and that we'll
actually see a continuation of the scene
where he found fennec i think this would
be an amazing way to connect everything
together and it would also allow us to
finally see how barbara nursed her back
to health we know that it will be coming
at some point because the flashbacks are
all sort of telling the story of exactly
what happened in the build up to the
mandalorian season 2 episode 1. i
actually think the full flashback story
will culminate with boba searching for
kobanth and he'll nc mandel riding
across the desert much like how he did
at the end of that episode gives me
goosebumps just thinking about how
everything could all be connected and as
always you know it it's all connected
now why this might not be the case yeah
and why i might be an idiot is because
of the timeline that was set up in the
mandalorian we know that it takes place
five years after return of the jedi and
it's difficult to tell how long boba was
actually with the tuscans he may have
been a prisoner for a while and then
slowly have earned their trust but i am
curious to see exactly what the timeline
of this whole thing is now the other way
that this could happen is that baba will
go out and get the nectar's riders and
then he'll come across fennec in the
desert right after this i kind of think
that the pair will team up to take them
down though and that will be where they
really form their bonds i am expecting
their meeting to be the next big thing
and i am curious as to where fett parked
slave one that's still somewhere out
there and it was never addressed in
return of the jedi or the mandalorian we
know from mando season 2 that he and
fennek ride out on it to catch back up
with mando and grogu and i'm guessing
this might tie in with the slave one
seen from the trailer either that or he
goes and gets it and just [ __ ] all and
he toes up but yeah that's how i can see
things happening now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the show and if
you're enjoying the video so far we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up if
this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul now let's get into the
rest of the breakdown okay so now the
season is setting the pike sub as being
the big bad i can't see them being the
major threat in the series pikes are
pretty vicious but they're definitely
not enough to scare two huts off the
planet because of this i actually think
it's going to be kira who's the one
behind everything and that she'll be
played once more by emilia clarke when
we last saw kira she was reporting to
darth maul aka the head of the crimson
dawn now we know from the animated
series that obi-wan and maul went
head-to-head once more and that the
former killed him this means that
crimson dawn had an opening and i can
see kira being the person that stepped
into his place to take the reins of the
organization she's likely been
harvesting tatooine for spice in order
to build her empire as the trade in that
narcotic has helped to support criminal
activities throughout the entire galaxy
now going beyond that i kind of think
it's gonna tie in with a reported cameo
that's been put out there by several
newspapers
if you don't want to know and you don't
like it then don't watch it peace anyway
we have a laugh at the channel that we
are we have we have a laugh us too are
you still there well yeah several
newspapers over the last couple of weeks
have reported that harrison ford will be
returning his hand solo in a cameo role
similar to how mark hamill did in the
mandalorian these wikileaks stayed that
for travel to london for a couple of
days of filming last year and that he'll
be showing up dhd in the series you
should always take articles like this
with a grain of spice but as he of
course had a major rivalry with fete it
does make sense that they try to have
the two together on screen at some point
in this season beyond that though
there's also his romance with kira that
ended with her ditching him so that she
could go off and join crimson dawn if
she is the big bad i can actually see
solo showing up at some point to put a
stop to whatever it is she's doing the
last thing that the rebels need right
now is a criminal empire rising in place
of the galactic one and solo being so
closely connected to her could make for
a really good scene in which the pair
both get some closure i think that solo
might also get boba in a position where
he could kill him but he'll not as he'll
realize the positivity that he could
bring by being in charge now i say
positivity very lightly but unlike the
other crime lords that have come in
before him fett is super respectful and
would rather avoid conflict if necessary
i know one of the main criticisms
surrounding the show is that they've
toned down how ruthless he is and i
might have even chuckled at the term
beta fett but that doesn't mean i agree
yeah
but that was a pretty funny name yeah i
must admit now that is pretty much just
running things completely different to
what's come before and i think because
of this that he'll actually manage to
outlast the other crime lords that have
all fallen because of this i think that
come the end of the season that that
will pretty much be running most of the
syndicates and we do know from the
trailers that he meets with the
clitonians the aqualish and also the
transoceans i think this will also come
pretty soon and possibly even in episode
four it shows that he's trying to work
with everyone so in turn they all work
for him and potentially solo seeing that
someone is keeping the criminals in line
will mean that he'd rather have that
than the potential pablo esco huts that
are the alternatives i'd love to see the
series end with bet being the best of a
bad bunch that's given leeway by the
rebels as long as he promises to keep
everyone in line i think that would be a
bittersweet way to close out the show
and we could also see him riding a
rancor off into those twin sunsets with
fennek at his side anyway we're still
pretty early on in the series so there's
a major possibility that several things
could change and that all these
predictions will be wrong in less than
two days but thanks for watching you
sucker just go easy on me when these all
turn out to be wrong yeah just be like
well you you give a guess we'll give you
that and i'll appreciate it yeah i'll
tell you what as a thank you you'll get
entered into a competition on the 30th
of january in which we're giving away
three mcu box sets all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check our
breakdown of episode 3 which will be
linked on screen right now we pointed
out all the easter eggs we could find
gave our theories for the future and
it's definitely worth watching right
after this without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been poor
let's see in the next one take care
peace
you